Rushmore is red. It's traffic. Result. Um,
traffic removes the Labour in Rushmore.
It's the first time that we've had a Labour council.
Labour left council in Rushmore in the 50 years of its existence.
So, um,
I think it's a real tribute to the way the Labour Party's changed
under Kia Psalms leadership.
Um, people are trusting Labour now to make a change.
They've fed up with the conservatives.
They've had 24 years here of the conservatives in power
and they want Labour to deliver a change.
I think it's just, uh,
a general feeling that the whole country is fed up with the Tories.
So whether it's the local council mismanaging things
or it's the wider picture,
I think people are fed up with conservatives
and just can't wait for general election
and they can't wait for Rishi Sunak to have the courage to call one.
It is both frozen, I think,
for local residents as well.
A really disappointing evening.
I think some people clearly do vote on a national basis.
That's always gonna be the case.
Some people do view local council elections
as a way of being able to express a view about what's happening
Westminster. We saw today,
for example, in many of our crucial wards,
hundreds of votes going to the Reform Party.
Now, the Reform Party literature was all talking about national issues.
It was talking about things like immigration and such,
like which we as a borough council have no control over.
Whatsoever, so many people did get energised by those issues
and choose to vote along those lines.
It was also that we saw from the other parties,
them leaning into national,
national messaging and what they're putting us in the local level.
So clearly that did have an impact.
But we're not here to make excuses.
We're here to listen to what we've heard from residents.
We're going to work even harder to try and represent our awards.